you got to me about the situation with
them with Destin house Destin do it um
he's doing well you know basically as
you know I've been you know leaked to
the to the media we basically decided to
take a few days off initially as a
precaution it was around the same time
that you know people were starting to
get more cautious and so we thought hey
you know why not be proactive in this
regard and and kind of let's have
everyone stay home for a few days while
we sort this stuff out and see you know
get a couple people tested see what the
results are and thankfully you know
everybody came back all well and good
but you know as each day progressed it
became more and more apparent that
things were not going to go back to the
way they were and so you know that
turned into let's stay home for two
weeks and reevaluate then and then very
very quickly that turned into the yeah
we don't know when we're coming back and
and I feel like that's kind of been
pretty much on pace with with what the
rest of the world has been has been up
to right I mean it's like every day you
wake up you get more information you get
news on how these different governments
around the world are handling it some
better than others and yeah for fur you
know for better for worse now we're all
we're all kind of here and we're all
going through it what was your initial
reaction I mean like you just it was in
phases of like okay here's this news
okay now I'm gonna pull back a bit now
gonna really just like go on haters what
was your thought what was your reaction
I mean honestly I think in the beginning
I was just I was just so focused on I
wanted everybody to be okay you know
especially like you mentioned you know
you know we had Destin who was a new
parent you know undergo testing and it
was a precaution we knew the chances
were low but still I think you know more
than anything I just we all just wanted
to make sure that everybody in our and
our family was okay and then when we
realized it was a bigger thing than kind
of anybody had anticipated that kind of
that I feel like that kind of empathy
turned towards the rest of the world you
know
at this point it's like what what can i
really say other than you know we're all
we don't know when we're gonna get back
nobody knows when they're gonna get back
to their lives either and and really
it's just a matter of like how can we
how can we you know do our part to make
sure that this doesn't hey this doesn't
go on for any longer than it than it has
to and be you know the people who are
working every single day whether that's
in you know essential services frontline
health care or just like you know the
jobs that that keep our world turning
like running public transportation and
you know making sure those those
positions are filled I mean how do we
make sure that those people are the best
support that they possibly can be that's
honestly been the number one thing
that's on my mind yeah I loved reading
she imposed about your birthday wish can
you uh can you talk about that about
about your connection to the hospital in
asada sure sure yeah so I mean for you
know my birthday is coming up it's this
this Sunday April 19th and obviously
this is a bit of an abnormal birthday
it's not how I imagined I'd be spending
my my 31st birthday Oh 31 but it's a you
know it if you were to asked me what I
want what I want for my birthday more
than anything it would just be to make
sure that you know that that a the world
is safe and B of course you know that
that my friends and family are safe and
you know my mind kept going to my
parents who are you know like you like
half the world away and you know I just
thought about my mind went to trillion
immediately because trillion was the
hospital that you know my mother got had
surgery and and my grandfather recently
had cataract surgery and you know my
grandmother's getting treated for for
Alzheimer's so it's been a big part of
of our lives you know as as kind of
Mississauga Mississauga residents and so
I just wanted to I just wanted to shed a
little bit of light on that organization
I put it up on Instagram and and I
wanted to make sure that anybody who
donated knew that I was I was very
personally grateful so I just yeah I
just put up you know hey just DN me not
only not only if you donate to Trillium
but really just any health care
organization whether it's one that you
support leo locally and wherever you're
from
and yeah I got it I got an overwhelming
response and I'm still having to you
know make these these video responses
and and honestly it's just such a it's
it's an honor to be able to do that and
I'm blown away again I'm so happy and so
happy to do these videos and I'm so
happy that there's a lot of them right
it shows that I think at this time
people are predominantly you know very
compassionate and are looking to give in
any way that they can and of course you
know what it all comes down to it the
best thing that you can do and the most
that you can give at this point is to
just kind of stay home when you can and
and you know obey obey these rules that
have been set out for us and and really
just to not get yourself in a too much
trouble right now yeah I think you know
a couple weeks ago at least with my
folks like with my dad yeah
conversation was like you gotta stay
home man like you can't get out there
you can't go to work and he was a bit
dense about it sorry Deadpool offense
but now it's like people are getting it
right people gotta understand they gotta
stay in what's it like where you are
like if you look out your window yeah in
Australia what's the light well it's
it's currently 11:00 at night so not
much going on not that they're not that
there would be more otherwise but you
know when I look out yeah I see the I
see the circular key ferry terminal I
see the Sydney Harbour Bridge both like
you know huge iconic Australian
landmarks and it's just it is just a
ghost town which I think speaks to you
know how seriously people are taking it
which is good I know a few weeks ago
there was some viral stuff that surfaced
about Bondi Beach and you know just how
packed it was despite there being a
pandemic and I think after that
Australians got the message and they and
they're really really state I mean and I
mean to be fair like I think we all came
to you know I think we all came to it at
different rates right I think the first
time that we heard about this virus we
were like oh it seems like it's far away
you know it seems like it's it's you
know a couple of people have it but it
seems mostly under control and then
quickly when that didn't become the case
we had to adjust but of course everyone
adjust at their own rate as long as
right now in this moment everyone is you
know on board with with staying home and
yeah doing their part yeah
now that you're on this downtime what's
the what's the regimen like for keeping
in touch with Shane to people with more
bizarre like an ABS check does Kevin
Feige like FaceTime you and it's like
let's see those ABS you got to make sure
those abs are still still right there
buddy I can tell you that if there if
there was such an app check I think I
would definitely be sailing you know I
have you know what I've been doing is
I've been getting into a lot of Animal
Crossing right then I've been building
building up that house I've got I've got
two rooms now I'm looking forward to
adding a third one making sure my
islands well-developed got what else got
into tick tock which which you know you
have as well so you know you're looking
for sweating getting some pointers from
you on that but you know we can't win on
tick tock yeah this is amazing this is
amazing when today right here I don't
think we ever I didn't plan it
no evidently you know you and I just
both have amazing sense of fashion so
it's it have you been in touch with them
your akim's castmates um you know what
we did we did a little zoo session for
our season finale which was just about a
maybe a week or two ago I don't I don't
even know anymore
I cannot gauge time at all but it was it
was really really wonderful to see
everybody again and we kind of took some
live questions and also had the chance
to catch up with each other and you know
of course of course I miss them very
dearly I can't wait to get back as I as
I'm sure that I will at some point you
know we're very happy to receive news
that were renewed for another couple of
seasons and I have every intention of
coming back for those so yeah amazing
that's fantastic news for lots of Kim's
fans only all your fan in for two so
this film though I mean they've been
watching you doing your do your martial
arts watching you doing all your
tricking and flipping I know that you
can't say much I get that do you
describe your feeling Oh
what it was like to get there cuz before
you left me we chatted about how the
opening is and how amazing the whole
experience was gonna be for you when you
finally got there and kind of process of
it how does it feel oh my god it was it
was it was like everything I imagined it
would be and more which is why these
last few but this these last couple of
months have been like set like the
ultimate come down from you know when we
last checked in which was like
unbelievable you know hi in my life and
this is just like of course I'm like
sitting there being like wow how things
like how different the world looked six
months ago yeah I can't wait for I can't
wait for things to just get back to
normal I can't wait to go for a walk you
know when it's when it's safe of course
and and of course I can't wait to see
everybody on set again it was it was
actually such an incredible experience I
can't wait to if I ever see when there's
not a camera rolling I'd be happy to
share all the stories with you